right as you just saw President Trump
moments ago wrapping up a toast with the
French president at the first state
dinner now this special relationship
blossoming between the President and
president McCrone it's just one aspect
as one of huge Trump diplomatic success
now the mainstream media won't report
this but the Trump administration they
are making incredible strides all over
Asia in fact with every passing day the
u.s. is now getting closer and closer to
holding direct talks with North Korea
now just this week the dictator Kim
jong-un made a series of concessions
including the suspension of all
ballistic missile testing the closure of
a nuclear development site and North
Korea's rocket man even dropped a demand
that the u.s. troops leave the Korean
Peninsula now earlier today President
Trump lauded this progress and even had
kind words for Kim jong-un and his
newfound willingness to compromise on
the world stage watch this Kim Jong was
he really has been very open and I think
very honorable from everything we're
seeing now a lot of promises have been
made by North Korea over the years but
they've never been in this position I
hope that we will be able to deal in a
very open and honorable fashion with
North Korea I started a process and when
I did everybody thought I was doing it
absolutely wrong but in the meantime for
25 years people have been dealing and
nothing happened and all that's
happening right now and I think we're
doing very well meetings are being set
up
and I want to see Dee nuclearization of
North Korea a lot of concessions have
already been made we have made no
concessions despite some of the media
saying that I've made concessions I
don't I haven't even discussed the
concession quite naturally instead of
reporting the diplomatic progress on the
Korean Peninsula which the whole world
good safer if it works oh you're a
mainstream media of course twisting
those remarks in order to trash the
president once again
and of course distract their viewers
from Trump's undeniable initial success
all over the world stage let's take a
look at this he said that President Kim
that North North Korea's dictator Kim
jong-un is at
has been very open and very honorable
and how they have been dealing with I
guess planning out there their meeting
to come what do you make of that that's
a it's quite a strong adjective to use
for a dictator of a nation that in
prisons its people he talked about how
great Kim Jong is being you must talk
about this just for a moment yeah did he
call him a great leader I don't know if
you use word greatly I don't know if you
can in just in real terms whether you
could ever call him open if any other
president democrat or republican had
used such words Donald Trump would have
been the first person to say it's
outrageous to say that a dictator to
someone who represses all the human
rights in his country that lets his
people starve
that takes Americans as hostage is open
and honorable when I heard the word
honorable I thought of the otto warmbier
his parents who saturday it used to
seats with me just so many months ago
talking about their son who was tortured
in North Korea
how was kim jeong-hoon honorable there's
nothing honorable about kim jonghwan
he's a sociopath
what you just saw another example the
mainstream media attacking this
president no matter what he does if he
gave ten million dollars to every person
on earth they'd say why not 11 i guess
they forgot about all of trumps peace
through strength strategy and how it's
working with the united states remember
we sent multiple Carrier Strike groups
to the region we increased the sanctions
on this rogue regime we pressured China
and they helped oh yeah and the
president called out little rocket man's
terrible treatment of his own people in
a very clear and public way without
backing down the media is not used to
this no one has shown more contempt for
other nations and for the well-being of
their own people than the depraved
regime in North Korea it is responsible
for the starvation deaths of millions of
North Koreans and for the imprisonment
torture killing and oppression of
countless more tohara of life in North
Korea is so complete that citizens pay
bribes to government officials
have themselves exported aboard as
slaves they would rather be slaves than
live in North Korea
no regime has oppressed its own citizens
more totally or brutally than the cruel
dictatorship in North Korea North
Korea's reckless pursuit of nuclear
missiles could very soon threaten our
homeland alright time for a history
lesson remember it was only a few months
ago the mainstream media said that top
Donald Trump's tough action his rhetoric
it would result in a nuclear holocaust
this was their predictions watch this
the idea of a nuclear showdown with
North Korea keeps you up at night I
would recommend deleting your Twitter
app he is not merely being cavalier with
a threat about nuclear war he's being
cavalier in a way that it makes him seem
demented these are the messages from a
person who is not well from a leader who
is not fit for office president Trump is
goading Kim jong-un to test a nuclear
missile again to prove its reliability
to show him wrong and fundamentally I
think it comes across as to
kindergarteners who are jostling each
other except that each has nuclear
weapons after a hundred thousand
Americans die after a nuclear holocaust
or after a million die inside us where
we are this is not an exaggeration
Trump's comments about nuclear weapons
have experts worried he could literally
inadvertently trigger a catastrophe
TAS Rafi all right let's get this
straight President Trump takes very
tough action and the media has a melt
out this strategy actually brings Kim
jong-un to the negotiating table talking
about denuclearization of the entire
Korean Peninsula the president makes
encouraging remarks and the media still
has a meltdown you know what the media
didn't have a meltdown over how about
Obama's appeasement of the mullahs in
Iran in what is probably the dumbest
single deal in the history of mankind
where the United States of America where
your ex-president gave away a hundred
and fifty billion of your dollars
cargo planes full of cash and other
currencies to a regime the chance death
to America death to Israel on a weekly
basis burns our flag burns the Israeli
flag all because of a promise from Iran
to temporarily halt their nuclear
weapons program but they still got to
spin their centrifuges and we didn't get
to inspect anything that's the dumbest
deal ever you also didn't see a media
freak out remember Bill Clinton he said
there's a good deal of American people
his appeasement of North Korea Kim
jong-il Kim jong-un's father remember
this diplomatic dereliction take a look
this is a good deal for the United
States North Korea will freeze and then
dismantle its nuclear program South
Korea and our other allies will be
better protected the entire world will
be safer as we slow the spread of
nuclear weapons South Korea with support
from Japan and other nations will bear
most of the cost of providing North
Korea with fuel to make up for the
nuclear energy it is losing and they
will pay for an alternative power system
for North Korea that will allow them to
produce electricity while making it much
harder for them to produce nuclear
weapons the United States and
international inspectors will carefully
monitor North Korea to make sure it
keeps its commitments only as it does so
well North Korea fully join the
community of nations didn't work out too
well so it's time to learn from the
failures on the world stage appeasement
never works it incurs aggression now
this is something former President
Reagan knew all too well which is why he
refused to relent refused to appease
refused to placate the Soviet Union the
former evil empire as he described them
now back then many on the Left were also
predicting the worst that Reagan would
bring us to the brink of nuclear war and
what happened the Berlin Wall came
tumbling down there is one sign that the
Soviets can make that would be
unmistakable
that would advance dramatically
dramatically the cause of freedom and
peace general secretary Gorbachev if you
seek peace if you seek prosperity for
the Soviet Union and Eastern Europe if
you seek liberalization come here to
this gate mr. Gorbachev open this gate
mr. Gorbachev tear down this wall and
the wall came down well more on
presidents from significant diplomatic
progress all throughout the show we'll
show you how bribing dictators and
kissing the rings of despot and
murderers has failed all throughout
history now let's turn to a brand new
explosive report from our own Sarah
Carter uncovering a damning new
revelation about what a serious
misconduct at some of the highest levels
in our government now according to Sarah
tonight multiple sources are saying that
fired FBI deputy director Andrew McCabe
issued a stand-down order during the
initial phases of the FBI's
investigation into Hillary Clinton's
private email server and according to
Carter sources tonight McCabe was
overseas when he became aware of the
investigation and sent electronic
communications voicing his displeasure
with agents in other words doing their
job one FBI official tells Sarah Carter
quote McCabe tried to steer people off
the private email investigation that
appears to be obstruction and should be
investigated now this of course comes on
the heels of the IG report on McCabe's
firing revealing quote McCabe said that
a high-ranking Obama Justice Department
official expressed concerns about FBI
agents taking overt steps in the Clinton
Foundation investigation during the
presidential campaign so it's clear that
during the 2016 presidential election
the deep state as we have now been
reporting over a year was alive and well
now we have reached out to Andrew McCabe
for comment we have yet to hear back and
also breaking tonight Sarah Carter just
tweeted out DOJ will make the six months
of missing text that were eventually
located by the IG that's Horowitz
between struck and paid
available to Congress sometime tonight
or tomorrow according to sources that's
developing now we will comb through all
of those text if it when they become
available this is a huge development and
meanwhile we know the two House
Committee Chairman Bob Goodlatte trey
Gowdy they are making huge strides on
their efforts to hold this deep state
accountable now this week the two
Republican congressman in fact struck a
deal with the Department of Justice and
will now gain access to documents
surrounding the FBI's investigation into
Hillary Clinton and how she mishandled
classified information on her
unauthorized private email server these
new developments should shine a light on
why James Comey gave white gloves
special treatment to Hillary while
turning a blind eye to her serious
crimes do we have equal justice under
the law tonight there's a new report
James Comey has lawyered up and he has
in fact tapped a personal friend former
US attorney to help him navigate the
current muddy legal waters surrounding
him we did reach out to commis attorney
for comment he said he's been a part of
commis legal team since May of 2017 news
to me tonight I have some friendly
advice for commis lawyer you might want
to acclimate your client with 18 USC 793
about leaking classified information
which is a serious crime and your client
needs to be held accountable I have said
many times this year 2018 is the year
the boomerang and now it's time for the
disgraced former FBI director to answer
for his deliberate improper and now
potentially criminal actions I have told
you this is the biggest abuse of power
corruption scandal in the history of
this country the media's been entirely
missing in action the entire time and
the same can be said of the many people
at the highest levels of power sadly no
wonder why they attacked me in this show
pretty much hourly daily Hannity Hannity
Hannity